bonsoir et bienvenue pour cette nouvelle
édition du 78 sur TVfil 78 18h si vous
nous rejoignez en direct en ce 12
février le premier invité de ce soir est
André vanonolbec bonsoir vous êtes le
maire de loufcienne et Doren avant le
nouveau président du Nouveau Centre dans
le département des Yvelines quel place
pour votre formation politique aussi
bien dans le département qu'au niveau
national vous nous le direz tout à
l'heure pour le moment voici les titres
en image quelques un des sujets qui
seront développés au cours de cette
édition Philippe Briot le maire du
chînet a lancé une pétition nationale
contre le mariage pour tous et pour
demander un référendum il a recueilli
plus de 500000 signatures la barrière
est donc franchie pour obtenir une
saisine du Conseil économique et social
et
environnemental mobilisation dans
l'enseignement ce mardi pour protester
contre la la mise en œuvre de la réforme
des rythmes scolaires un mouvement très
suivi dans l'agglomération de
Saint-Quentin et notamment à trrappe à
la fois par des professeurs syndiqués et
par d'autres qui ne le sont pas à
l'image de José Cachin enseignant à
Montini le bretonne autre manifestation
avec comme seul mot d'ordre le sourire
et la bonne humeur c'était le défilé des
étudiants de la Faculté des sciences de
la santé à Montini Mardi Gras oblige et
c'était plutôt coloré vous le voyez
quand un composteur devient esthétique
c'est le Champi compost m en place au
ager du Roi à Versailles un outil
pédagogique pour apprendre à réaliser du
bon compost tout est une question
d'équilibre paraît-il et nous en
parlerons tout à l'heure d'environnement
et là on sera également en question dans
une demi-heure pas plus une demi-heure
et on vous retrouvera Valérie oribo
bonsoir bonsoir wfred oui nous parlerons
de l'habitat bioclimatique qui sera
notre habitat de demain et qui devrait
même être déjà celui d'aujourd'hui nous
en parlerons avec Yan Girbau de l'ALC
l'Agence Locale de l'énergie et du
climat de Mani lesamo une demi-heure
promis dans une demi-heure pileepoil la
page environnement du mardi sur TV film
et on débute donc par la politique le
nouveau centre qui s'organise avant les
municipales mais quelle place pour la
formation centriste dans cette vie
politique André vonolbec est donc le
premier invité de cette édition avant
même de parler du nouveau centre de
votre formation politique j'aimerais
tout de même votre réaction concernant
la mobilisation autour du mariage pour
tous et le maire du chînf Philippe Briot
centralise tout toutes les pétitions
afin d'obtenir justement cette saisine
du Conseil économique social et
environnemental qui permettrait de
revoir un petit peu la décision prise
cet après-midi par les députés puisque
cet après-midi les députés ont validé
cette ouverture du mariage à l'ensemble
des couples
homosexuels il il dit Philippe briillot
avoir reçu plus de 500000 signatures
est-ce que vous faites partie des
signataires tout d'abord oui vous l'avez
soutenu alors expliquez-nous les
motivations votre démarche pourquoi
soutenir et demander juste justement
cette que que le gouvernement et les
députés revoient un peu leur copie voilà
alors bon ma démarche est à la fois en
tant
que engagé politique et également en
tant que
maire en fait le mariage pour tous tel
qu'il est conçu et disons met en cause
un certain nombre de repères et un
certain nombre de valeurs
et disons que je considère que il ouvre
la porte à disons
la procréation médicale assistée et
disons un principe d'adoption qui est
mal défini et donc c'est scienciellement
c'est pas l'acte lui-même mais c'est le
disons la l'ouverture qui est faite et
qui remet en cause un peu les fond de
notre société donc je ne suis pas
favorable à C dispositif et par
conséquent j'ai fait partie des
signataires car je pense que c'est
effectivement un des moyens de disons de
de faire réfléchir en quelque sorte et
de faire comprendre à l'ensemble des
Français les risques que comportent ces
dispositifs mais ça sert véritablement à
quelque chose aujourd'hui ce sont les
les députés qui se sont exprimés 329
voix pour
229 contre vois ça va servir finalement
les députés sont proncés maintenant ce
seront les sénateurs qui devront voter
ce sera le 2 avril d'ailleurs ex oui oui
bon personnellement je suis républicain
il y a eu des élections c'est la
majorité qui qui dirige ce que je
voudrais dire c'est que les électeurs en
fait ont soutenu François Hollande et
ont élu des députés socialistes de façon
majoritaire ça veut pas dire queils sont
d'accord avec l'ensemble du programme et
je pense que effectivement un débat
nationale est nécessaire une
explicationpasse le clivage
gauche-droite aujourd'hui ça dépasse le
clivage gauche- drroite c'est évident
don il y a un certain nombre de
d'ailleurs vous l'avez vu dans le vote
des députés hein non je pense que
l'élection
disons la la majorité a donc gouverné la
France mais en ce qui concerne des
sujets de de société aussi important il
faut qu'il y ait un débat un débat
important dans la société pour que
chacun comprenne les tenants les
aboutissants vous restez avec nous sur
ce plateau on va parler dans quelques
instants donc du nouveau centre de votre
élection à sa tête dans le département
des Yvelines pour l'instant nous allons
justement au chînet où Philippe Briot le
maire continue à compter les signatures
même s'il a dépassé les 500000
nécessaires pour cette saisine veut
renforcer un peu plus la légitimité de
sa
démarche nous voici au centre de
dépouillement de la pétition contre le
mariage pour tous au chaîné lundi soir
la barre des 500000 signatures le nombre
requis pour saisir le Conseil économique
social et environnemental était franchi
552000 signatures exactement et quand on
voit cette soixantaine de bénévoles qui
s'activ le chiffre risque encore de
grimper il en arrive tous les jours tous
les jours puis il y a surtout des gens
qui apportent des paquets
entiers hier on a eu vu débarquer de
l'avion une personne avec une grande
valise qui venait de la Martinique avec
je crois 7 8000 pétitions comme Martin
auienne vient tous les jours aider à
compter et classer les signatures cette
salle municipale prêtait au collectif la
manif pour tous est devenue sa deuxième
maison comme beaucoup de ses volontaires
elle a le sentiment de participer à un
combat citoyen le but c'est de faire
entendre notre voix la voix de tous les
Français et pas juste une élite de Paris
et quelques lobbyistes bien financé
c'est la révolte citoyenne c'est
aujourd'hui le pouvoir va passer dans la
rue on risque peut-être la manif pour
tous d'être le premier parti politique
en France vendredi devant le siseu c'est
en effet la première fois que le cise le
Conseil économique social et
environnemental a été saisi par pétition
le collectif a rendez-vous vendredi
matin signature sous le bras ou plutôt
dans plusieurs camions si le compte est
validé le C aura un an pour rendre son
avis et pour avoir plus de poids le
collectif a décidé de poursuivre le
comptage jusqu'à la prochaine réunion du
CZE le 26 février on dépassera largement
le million de pétition et là vraiment on
aura un observatoire du mécontentement
des Français et on passer à pas pour les
marginaux malgré cette mobilisation le
projet de loi avance et poursuit son
agenda l'Assemblée nationale doit voter
la loi aujourd'hui le Sénat quant à lui
l'examinera le 2 avril et cette cette
loi justement a été voté aujourd'hui à
l'Assemblée en fin d'après-midi 329 voix
pour et une dizaine d'abstention après
le mariage pour tous nous parlons à
présent du Nouveau Centre des autres
formations centristes également André
vanonolbeck président du Nouveau Centre
dans les ivelines élu début février face
à asis c'estny personnage plutôt
médiatique entrepreneur de de mant la
jolie que nous avons déjà reçu sur ce
plateau vous avez totalisé 55 % des voix
comment s'est passé justement cette
campagne c'était une ambiance un peu
particulière pendant 2 ans il n'y avait
pas eu d'élection exactement la
fédérationoise au sein de la fédération
la Fédération ivlinoise effectivement a
été mise en sommeil en quelque sorte et
était disons dirigé directement par le
Comité Exécutif National ce qui fait que
d'après le principe de subsidiarité on
voit tout de suite que le fonctionnement
était pas très mobilisateur bon les
instances nationales ont décidé de de
l'organisation de d'élections et donc
nous avons tout début du mois
organiser ces élections au cours de
laquelle il y a eu l'élection à la fois
d'un président d'un conseil
départemental et de représentants au
Conseil national asis SNI cette campagne
face à lui comment elle s'est déroulé
justement asis S qui avait été plutôt
critique au moment où il n'y avait pas
d'élection il y a eu pas mal d'agitation
également notamment après le retrait de
la candidature d'Hervé Morin dans la
course à la présidentielle sétait aussi
exprimé comment s'est passé la la
campagne avec vous alors il y avait une
une différence d'approche c'est-à-dire
que asisé en fait est est un militant HM
h euh il est et par contre il est pas
élu donc il a il a pas eu l'occasion de
se confronter à la gestion euh d'une
commune ou euh voir euh de participer à
la gestion d'un département ou d'une
région et dans son approche c'était
essentiellement une approche donc
militante il faut euh euh augmenter le
nombre d'adhérents euh et euh faire des
campagnes médiatiques euh euh pour pour
ma part
moi je je me présenta en tant que maire
en tant qu'ancien délégué de l'UDF
délégué départemental de l'UDF et euh à
l'approche des élections municipales je
pense qu'il était nécessaire que le
parti soit représenté par un élu et si
possible un maire il y a une certaine
logique entre le calendrier et le choix
qu'on fait les militants aujourd'hui la
famille nouveau centre est réconcilié
tout va bien parce que il y a quelques
temps vous avez été suspendu aussi en
tout cas mis en congé du du parti lors
des élections sénatoriales c'était en
2011 vous aviez maintenu votre
candidature sans avoir l'investiture du
nouveau centre qui était revenu à à
roselcoss qui était la sénatrice
sortante puisqu'elle avait remplacé
Nicolas Abou au Sénat elle a perdu
d'ailleurs depuis depuis son siège
depuis cette élection aujourd'hui vous
avez réintégré le parti tout va bien
tout se passe bien mais oui tout se
passe bien euh bon mais sans revenir sur
le passé euh je signale quand même que
euh j'ai personnellement j'appartenais
au nouveau centre Rosel cross
n'appartenait pas au nouvel centre h au
nouveau centre elle était donc au modem
mais elle avait reçu l'investiture voilà
alors après il y a eu les discussions
qui se font dans les instance national
sous les ordres de la République et là
bon bah le choix a été pris et
effectivement personnellement je me suis
présenté mais il y a ça pas été un
traumatisme hein vous dit aujourd'hui
pas de traumatisme tout va bien mais
pour autant comment vous allez relancer
la machine nouveau centre ne serait-ce
que dans le département des Yveline
puisqueaujourd'hui il va falloir aller à
la rencontre des électeurs les échéances
électorales se rapprochent très très
vite mars 2014 c'est presque demain he
pour toutes les formations politiques on
y pense et plus que le matin on seron
d'ailleurs et bien en fait euh on va
aller au au devant des électeurs mais on
va y aller de façon très locale en
traitant des sujets qui concernent
directement l'électeur dans leur vie de
tous les jours et c'est vraiment le sur
ce registre là que nous allons aborder
les municipales parce que il y a des des
temps fort pour l'élection d'un
président de la République où on fait
des choix de société et puis il y a des
les élections municipales qui sont la
préoccupation des gens dans leur vie de
tous les jours et c'est dans ce sens-là
que le nouveau centre va agir Hervé
Morin le nouveau centre ça représente
quelque chose aujourd'hui vous pensez
pour les électeurs ah oui oui oui parce
que bon dans
le dans l'organisation en fait des des
des centristes il faut reconnaître que
on a rencontré quelques difficultés avec
d'une part la création de l'UMP qui a
vidé d'une partie de ses forces les le
courant centriste et puis ensuite il y a
eu la création du MoDem qui a fait
encore une cission et donc à force de
faire des cissions la particularité des
centristes c'est que ils ont les mêmes
le même idéal la même la même le même
courant de pensée mais alors pour
réussir à s'entendre il a un côté
Gaulois chez les centristes fa connaîre
malgré tout il y a une tentative he
peut-être de Jean-Louis borlau c'est de
fédérer la plupart des forces centristes
au sein de de l'UDI le nouveau centre en
fait partie d'ailleurs exactement donc
Jean-Louis blot ben
reprend refait une recomposition du
centre de la même façon que Giscard
destin l'avait fait uneépoque avec l'UDF
c'està-dire que l'UDI en fait est une
fédération de partis et non pas un parti
c'est un parti politique statutairement
mais en réalité dans son fonctionnement
c'est une falération de parti et le
nouveau centre peut exister au sein de
l'UD le nouveau centre peut exister
véritablement se faire entendre au sein
de oui oui oui va pas être encore plus
vidé justement comme ça avait été le cas
avec l'UMP ah non non non parce que là
on est partie prenante et même non non
on est écouté non non on est
suffisamment représentatif alors l'UDI
qui fédère ses différents partis
centristes notamment le nouveau centre
et puis le Parti radical également de
jean-lis Blot et puis il existe
également le modem modem qui à ce jour
en tout cas n'a pas rejoint l'UDI est-ce
que ça fait trop de formations centriste
c'est la question que nous sommes allés
poser aux ivelinois justement h il y a
une saturation de tout ça et là je coupe
le contact trop de parti centriste
nonili c'est important oui parce que
sans tous les autres ils se battent
séparément il faut l'intérêt c'est enfin
ce qu'il faudrait qu'il se mettent
d'accord on n pas l'impression forcément
que les parties qui sont actuellement en
place font grand-chose font avancer les
choses donc plein de parti ça sert pas
forcément à grandchose mais si dans le
TA il y en a un qui est bien ce sera pas
une mauvaise chose voilà des centristes
vous savez tantôt il penchent à gauche
tantôt ils pensent à droite alors ils
sont jamais centristes en fin de compte
hein les centr trist ils sont où est-ce
qu'ils sont au centre à droite à gauche
ou par rapport à la dernière réaction
qu'on vient d'entendre alors là je peux
répondre euh
le le nouveau centre est un parti de
centre droit c'est clair et d'ailleurs
c'est ce qui nous différencie de du
MoDem puisque le modem est comme le dit
votre votre personne qui est interviewé
c'est un coup à droite un coup à gauche
nous c'est clair on est dans on était
dans la majorité on est maintenant dans
l'opposition alors comment vous allez
vous organiser maintenant pour les
municipal après toutes ces précisions
que vous venez de nous apporter parti de
centre droit rapport toujours fort avec
l'UMP l'UDI également au municipal dans
le département des ivelines il y aura
des listes uniquement nouveau centre des
listes uniquement udi UMP il y aura des
fusions des discussions effectivement il
y aura et c'est un peu l'intérêt c'est
justement un des intérêts de cette union
de de l'UDI qui est disons un lieu de
concertation c'est-à-dire que il y a des
représentants du Nouveau Centre il y a
des représentants du Parti radical de la
Fédération Européenne et démocratique de
la Gauche moderne et nous nous
rencontrons entre nous alors on passe en
revue nous allons passer en revue les
différentes communes où il y a des des
des personnes ou des élus qui veulent ou
se être conduits ou des des personnes
qui veulent constituer une liste on va
en discuter entre nous pour ne faire
qu'une seule liste qui est la liste udi
donc il a c'est un lieu de concertation
ça c'est pour l'UDI par rapport à l'UMP
alors par rapport à l'UMP ben alors je
vous précise qu'on est de centre droit
donc notre objectif
et sera dans le cadre des municipales
d'une part de reprendre un certain
nombre de villes qui ont basculé à
gauche alors que sociologiquement elles
le sont pas quelques villes par exemple
ah bah il y a eu bon parlons de poissie
poissie ça a été un un désaccord qui a
pu se passer avec le modème mais
logiquement bon
poissi il faut qu'il y ait une seule
liste qui se présente et cette liste a
de fortes chance de l'emporter cette
liste qui sera amené on va un nom Carl
olive Jean-François renal qui est le
secrétaire départemental alors je ch
bien du plaisir à l'UMP pour régler le
problème ils sont tous les deux UMP vous
avez pas de candidat préférés sur les
deux noms que je vous ai cité ah bon on
se prononcera après alors sur les autres
communes quel regard particulier
attentif ou non vous allez porter quels
sont les les communes où le nouveau
centre peut faire parler de lui
justement ah ben le nouveau centre bon
je peux au hasard j'en prends une
Loucienne par exemple ce serait plutôt
bien parce que c'est votre commune voilà
exactement non et puis il y a un certain
nombre de communes où on a des des élus
d'abord il y a quelques mares sortants
et puis il y a des des des communes où
il y aura une liste mais cette liste en
fait ne sera pas nouveau centre elle
sera une liste udi c'est-à-dire queil y
aura des composantes de l'UDI qui
participeront elle sera même et
d'ailleurs on l'espère dans la plupart
des cas des listes communes udi UMP ou
UMP pudi et au de 550 an en Yveline
puisque nous sommes sur le bassin de 50
an en Yveline vous êtes venu dans nos
studios à Guill encour est-ce qu'il y a
des des communes aussi où l'UDI va
pouvoir s'allier à l'UMP pour peut-être
inverser les tendances faire évoluer les
choses bon pour l'instant le le cas de
Guill en cour a pas encore été évoqué
mais la ligne de conduite est bien
celle-là c'est l'alliance avec l'UMP
dans les communes où il y a une
possibilité de reconquête donc dans tous
les cas l'UDI s'effacera pour laisser
l'UMP l'UDI va être un trempelin pour
l'UMP à moins que l'UMP s'efface pour
les cerudi ça fait aussi partie des
discussions que vous avez actuellement
évidemment oui oui oui on peut pas
rapport de force c'est pas le même alors
comment vous vous faites entendre
justement non et ben le rapport de force
quand on le prend globalement au niveau
du département par ex faut être lucide
le rapport est pas le même mais quand on
prend les les choses localement
localement il y a des endroits où l'UDI
il y a un électorat udi qui est plus
important qu'un électorat UMP donc là à
ce moment-là nos amis de l'UMP
comprendront très très bien que ce soit
l'UDI qui soit être de liste pour les
différentes investitures dans le
département des ivelines pour ces
municipales de 2014 mars 2014 quel
calendrier tout sera décidé quand oh oh
alors là c'est disons ce sera qu'au
dernier trimestre que les choses se
clarifieront hein merci d'être venu sur
notre plateau juste un dernier mot on va
faire le point dans un instant sur la
mobilisation des enseignants elle a été
plutôt forte contre cette réforme aussi
bien sur l'organisation dans l'éducation
que sur les rythmes scolaires forte
mobilisation aujourd'hui comment se sont
déroulé les choses dans votre commune
par exemple et puis quel regard vous
portez sur cette mobilisation
enseignante alors dans dans ma commune
effectivement et paradoxalement il y a
eu un taux de gréiste assez important
alors que en général les enseignants on
n'a pas l'occasion de fermer des écoles
alors que cette fois-ci il y a eu une
école qui a été fermée parce qu'il y
avait pas assez d'enseignants donc je
pense que le gouvernement devrait être
sensible à ce mouvement euh maintenant
le le principe de d'une réadaptation du
calendrier scolaire c'est un bon
principe et d'ailleurs il avait déjà été
le travail avait déjà été commencé au
cours du gouvernement précédent donc
c'est un bon principe la seule chose
c'est la mise en œuvre il faut faire
preuve de pédagogie il faut accepter de
de travailler mais dans ma commune nous
sommes en en relation la fois avec les
parents d'élèves et avec les enseignants
et les directrices d'école et on est en
train d'élaborer un projet dans la
concertation ce serait pour 2014 ou 2013
parce que c'est la grande question d'ici
fin mars commun qui doivent se prononcer
sur cette réorganisation du calendrier
scolaire non on prendra 2014 en fait
2014 pour deux raisons c'est que déjà le
gouvernement lui-même va peut-être
décider de le de reporter en 2014 c'est
dire qu'actuellement c'est 2013 et les
communes doivent prendre une
délibération pour demander l'exception
de commencant en 2014 je pense que ce
sera plutôt le contraire qui va se
passer et sur il y avait un aspect
financier qui était évoqué mais il
devient secondaire cont tenu des
positions qu'pris l'Assemblée le
l'assemblée des des maires de France
Merci Andr bolbe nouveau président du
Nouveau Centre dans le département des
zelin merci à vous cette mobilisation
enseignante justement on y revient avec
ce reportage de la rédaction Julie Rocha
Soarez Guillaume camp c'est Patrick
Jacques de
dixmud forte mobilisation dans
l'enseignement ce mardi en France et
dans les ivelines pour le report de la
réforme des rythmes scolaires parmi les
gréviste C deux enseignants non
syndiqués de l'école élémentaire Paul
for de Montin le
Bretonneux
c'est ce qui les agace le plus mais
pourquoi on arrive vraiment pas à faire
en sorte de laisser du temps aux gens
pour se concerter pour se mettre
d'accord sur un certain nombre de points
et que ces idées sans être édulcoré sans
être censuré ou on les vide de leur
substance alimente une loi et que ce
soit vraiment quelque chose qui emporte
l'adhésion passionné par leur métier ils
sont conscients de la nécessité d'une
réforme dans l'intérêt de l'enfant
l'idée du corp enseignant porter la
réforme payon à la rentrée 2014 afin de
réécrire le décret on doit repenser les
rythmes scolaires sur la journée sur la
semaine mais également sur l'année il y
a beaucoup de problèmes qui sont pas
résolus à l'heure actuelle à savoir les
activités qui sert proposées sur le
cadre périscolaire euh quelle formation
encadrée par quel personnel une question
de locaux qui se pose également bref on
se pose la question parce qu'on n pas
non plus envie que le temps périscolaire
se transforme en garderie pour ces
enseignants rien ne garantit
actuellement la qualité et la gratuité
du temps périscolaire pas de précision
non plus sur les programmes pourtant
jugés lourds et inadaptés selon le
syndicat SNU IPP Yveline le taux de
greviste s'élevait à près de 60 % ce
mardi dans le département 150 écoles sur
1000 seraient fermées à 50 ans iveline
une grève massivement suivie notamment à
montinis lebretonneux et l'encours
guillancour et la verrière attrape 30
écoles sur 36 étaient fermées ce mardi à
la mairie une centaine d'enseignants de
la ville a fait entendre ses inquiétudes
on peut pas laisser une réforme être
financée par les collectivités locales
parce que là c'est l'inégalité assurée
hein c'est voilà donc ça c'est ça c'est
insupportable sur trappe évidemment on
fera pas payer les les les activités
mais il y a des petites communes où on
élève les impôts locaux on fait payer
les les activités le coût de la réforme
à la mairie de Montini le Bretonneux on
l'a d'ors et déjà estimé 1 million et
demi d'euros par
an